for me i wanted you know the younger
kids to you know when they're growing up
and beard to look at bones highlighting
his resume i want to be like bones and
even better than bones bones
back cut for bones
and he's shaking folks
are shaking and rattling now straight
away got it
first thing obviously is the name
like just kind of sticks out to you so
give us like a little origin story how
that name all came about when i first
came to uh delaware
uh they only knew me as like the name
carolina because i was originally from
north carolina that's where i was born
at but i was raised in delaware but uh
the coach who had uh discovered me and
uh picked me like he picked me up and
like found me you know brought me to the
gym he started calling me carolina but
uh you know the childhood friends wanted
to know like my their own name for me
and uh i always was like had a slim
frame i was kind of skinny and uh one is
a boy he came up with the name busy and
i had another uh child friend she's a
girl and she came up with the name bones
and then i just put two and two together
you know it just came with busy bones
and ever since then it just stuck to me
and uh it fits me so well and that's
always gonna be my name you mentioned
the coach when you talk to that you talk
about the help that a coach just kind of
found you or whatnot you kind of speak
to that as well as like opportunities
that come you know like when you don't
have certain opportunities but then you
get a chance like the coach that came
and helped you out talk about a little
bit about that so when i first came from
north carolina uh you know i didn't know
anybody uh i didn't have no friends et
cetera et cetera but i would go down to
you know this gym it's called uh west
center city community center and uh
that's where everybody came to play
basketball you know just just have fun
there and uh you know he saw something
in me as a little kid and uh when he
first like discovered me he instantly
started calling me you know carolina i
introduced him to myself i told him you
know where i came from and stuff like
that he go by the name spoons and i'm
just like you know he introduced himself
to me too he like you know he's a coach
and stuff like that so i'm like you know
we're gonna have a bomb for sure because
you know he was one of the first person
i ever spoke to you know coming into the
city so ever since then he just been
like a father figure to me a role model
to me uh you know he taught me so many
uh life lessons and stuff like that now
that would always stick with me to this
day and uh he always believed in me so
it meant a lot to me because like i
didn't know anybody so you know him
taking me under his wing and showing me
the ropes as a young teenager and uh
just believe in me that meant a lot to
me what is the game of basketball taught
you as well it taught me so many
different things uh that that
still to this day i still like you know
think the game so much and i never take
for granted because uh you know i was in
numerous life situations where
basketball could have been taken away
from me and i i never want to take
basketball for granted because the
moment you know it was almost taken away
from me you know i cried my eyes out and
you know it made me appreciate the game
even more and thank the the lessons and
adversity and the stuff you go through
dealing with the game it it makes you
appreciate it even more yeah how much of
it was it just an escape for you you
know how much it was that you felt like
this is my avenue that i can like
completely pour myself into this and
give me a whole new life that i could
end up you know enjoying and living
man uh a lot honestly it's it's like
basketball like
it's it's that's that that space where
you know you just to just go into the
gym and lock in you know with yourself
it helped me you know figuring my own
stuff out you know sometimes you need to
be alone by yourself and do the thing
that you love and you get to you know
tap into different you know attributes
of yourself and learning yourself even
more and that's what uh you know growing
up with what i did with myself going
into the gym it just meant
just a lot to me just to be in a gym
with friends and also be in the gym by
myself because i learned so much about
myself i know that even personally like
just thinking about growing up like
didn't always have transportation didn't
always have the money to get these so
like even when you think about that in
the conversation around just access for
a lot of young athletes and people who
want to get into sports like what kind
of what is it that you're thinking about
when when these topics come up me
growing up i had to you know walk to
numerous gyms by 30 40 40 minute walks
just to get to the gym because i know
transportation sometimes you know it'll
be a van at a uh come to the you know
school after school you have to sit
outside and they'll come pick you up and
take you to the gym because you know the
sometimes it was so far and this was uh
community service stuff that the city
was providing and i was very thankful
for that because it'd be cold outside
you know snowing raining you know you're
not gonna walk in in a rain like that
but you wanna uh you know you wanna get
to the gym and play play basketball and
do the thing that you love but you know
growing up it was uh you know some
things like safe haven that's like after
hours like you know from 9 to 12 a.m you
know you've been in the gym you know the
people that's working it tell you
telling your parents where you at uh
they feed you you get to play basketball
and stuff like that but like as i got
older those stuff starting to like fade
away and there was more like the
violence and stuff like that the the
murder rate started to go up and that's
something i want to get back into you
know as i'm in a league now where i can
you know i can voice myself out to the
community and try to you know voice my
opinion and and and bring that you know
that joy back because when i was growing
up it was so much joy and now you're
seeing kids fading away in different
areas going left or going right instead
of just trying to you know keep straight
and that's something i want to do to
help to you know give back and and uh
just voice my opinion on that
what are some of the things maybe you're
excited about being able to give back to
to your community or just in general
being able to give back
uh you know partnering with uh under
armour would be huge for me to to give
back because uh they give that you know
the different level outlets where they
can you know help me even get involved
in the community to even give back so
you know that's another reason why i'm
invol uh partnering with under armour
we're hooked on this whole rookie class
we've loved that we've been undercover
for the last couple years so we're
really excited about and it's like your
game
is so different than everybody else's i
know that there's a lot that goes into
that game and there's a lot of pieces
that contributed to the way you play now
what really contributed to like making
your game what it is today growing up
everybody always asked me who i watched
and who was like a role model to me and
stuff like that i never really had like
you know somebody i looked up to but i
always watched no hot sauce growing up
and that was somebody you know to this
day you know i i just i just thank him
for being even alive just being able to
watch him on youtube like take some of
his moves his crossovers and stuff like
that and i always like text him and be
like you know bro i used to watch you
all the time he texted me back that that
means the most to me like i recently got
a phone call uh i was on facetime with
him you know doing a pre-drive process
and i was talking to him i'm like well
that's hot sauce you know that's like
one of the only person like i really get
hyped over to talk to because i
literally had come home from school eat
a bowl of cereal and after the bowl of
cereal i like dance in front in the
mirror with the basketball do the same
moves that he doing and uh it it just it
just gave me so many different levels
like you know that smoothness the skill
that like it just it just made me more
like comfortable with myself knowing
like that's the type of game that i want
to be able to play and adapt that into
the league and just you know just make
that my game and add my own flaring to
it so i definitely big pops to him for
sure you not know how hype you got me
man cause i you know
i'm from atlanta georgia we grew up
all we know he used to sleep at run
shoot we had a run and shoot man die see
you don't get me started that's crazy
i was not expecting an answer so
i saw you say a couple weeks ago that
like i want to be one of the greats you
know like what is it uh as well that
what fuels you to be that great and want
to be
a legend
man you know just to want my name to be
remember forever i don't want to just be
in this league and just be somebody you
know who came in the league and and not
have a resume for me i wanted you know
the younger kids to you know when they
growing up and beard look at bones
highland his resume i want to be like
bones and even better than bones so this
is what i'm doing it for for the for the
next generation and things like that and
also you know for for myself and and
wanting to keep better at myself what do
you want people to think about when they
say bones when they say bones highland
what do you want people to first think
about he's a joyful impactful kid who
can put a smile on anybody's face at any
given time any given moment that's what
i always live by i really appreciate
taking the time with us okay yes i
appreciate you yes yes